pau
[Musique]
on
aux sonorités de l'harmonium indien la
villa du département s'apprête à
célébrer le nouvel an tamoul une
manifestation culturelle organisée par
la région et le département de la
réunion le nouveau lanta on se fait dans
les maisons
le nouvel an parole se fait dans les
temps le nouvel an tamoul se fait dans
les collectivités
le nouvel an pas bruce se fait dans le
coeur de tous les réunionnais et cela
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant
et grâce à votre engagement a dit tous
les présidents d'associations et famille
qui au sein de la sphère intime
vous avez su garder les traditions
culturelles cultuelles les danse la
musique le manger la manière de
s'habiller
[Musique]
[Rires]
ce passage à la nouvelle année 5118 est
marqué par tout un ensemble de rituels
pour les familles indiennes
les associations partageront lors de
cette soirée leurs coutumes et leurs
croyances
ce taux le repas du midi se compose avec
les six groupes différents
c'est à dire
sucré l'acide amer exactement avec sa
symbolique que vous dire de la vie
normale il y a des bons côtés et mauvais
côtés
il ya des sucres d'où il ya 10 à m il ya
des bons il ya de mal donc il faut qu'on
est habitué avec sévit dans la vie
normale
c'est pour ça qu'on mange avec les
systèmes différents de leurs politiques
[Musique]
on est à la réunion et qu'on a des
spécificités spécificité de local
puisqu'on est dans ce vivre harmonieux
on est dans ce vivre ensemble où tous on
se côtoie moi j'irai avec plaisir en
tout cas je suis allé voir le jour en
chine moi j'irai bientôt voir l'aïd et
c'est ce partage qui nous permet
peut-être d'avoir cette cohésion d'avoir
cette paix qui n'est pas la même dans
tous les autres pays est vraiment ce
soir c'est un lieu magique qu'on partage
[Musique]
nous on fait du bas latin qu'ils ont
c'est une danse classique du sud de
l'inde du tamil nadu et
c'est une danse très symbolique avec
énormément de 2
valeur cette danse en fait vous dire le
bar the nation
le bar à vin qui veut dire l'expression
l'aragon la mélodie talent le rythme et
napier qui veut dire la danse donc c'est
la danse du rythme de la mélodie et une
expression
[Musique]